now let's proceed to vertex connection
and merging by Aaliyah area and
colleagues so what he proposes to do is
that we conditionally accept this path
the vertex next to XS but we pretend
that we indeed have to hit what this
basically means is that we have a biased
connection something that didn't really
happen but we pretend that it did and we
have this art that's the merging radius
so what this means is that on the left
side this X s star I would put on X s
instead if it is close by and by close
by we mean that it is in a circle that
is of radius R okay but what does this
give to me because this is a bias
technique if you add one more trick and
this trick would be making our decay
over time so this would shrink and
shrink and shrink and eventually it
would get to an epsilon value and that
to something that's very close to zero
in an infinite amount of time so the
bias would disappear from the renderer
in time that's quite remarkable I'll
tell you in a second why some results
with the vertex connection and merging
technique you can see that it can render
this difficult difficult SDS light
transport situation so this is indeed a
historical moment in global illumination
why because this kind of unifies biased
and unbiased photorealistic rendering
and that's huge that's huge because
biased and unbiased rendering was the
two biggest schools in photorealistic
image synthesis there were the unbiased
guys who were there rigorous scientific
let's sample all the light paths and
let's not cut corners type of people and
there were the biased guys who said that
okay let's cut corners because this
thing takes forever so let's use some
optimization techniques and what vertex
merging gives you is essentially an
algorithm that starts out biased but it
has less and less bias as time goes by
eventually ending up as an unbiased
technique so this is a historical moment
that
unifies unbiased and biased
photorealistic rendering wonderful piece
of work now a comparison first
bi-directional path tracing then
progressive photo mapping and vertex
connection and merging make sure to
check out the paper here onwards two
paths based regularization this is a
work of Anton Kaplan and colleagues is a
super smart guy at the kit and this is
essentially a generalization of vertex
connection and merging what is happening
is essentially not spatial but angular
regularization what does this mean what
we're looking for is connecting the
diffuse vertex to the specular with VCM
what you would do is you would continue
the light path from the light source and
you would hit a point that is nearby
this next specular vertex and you would
set this tolerance this radius this
merging radius R and if it's inside then
you accept the light path now this you
can call spatial regularization what
Anton is proposing is angular
regularization so you would say that you
will take a tolerance value in terms of
outgoing values and this intuition is
slightly different because what this
essentially means is that we have Delta
distributions for specular reflections
but we start out with a large angular
tolerance and this means that the
specular inter reflections will be
treated as if they were diffuse so the
mirror will show up as if it were a
completely white or some colored wall
and then it will slowly slowly converge
to being a mirror you can imagine this
distribution as what you see in the
right side that you have the blue the
diffuse ish brdf and you put your two
fingers on the sides of this and you
start pushing them together and this
push happens in time so as time goes by
we go from the blue to the orange to the
green and we would even squeeze this
green
more and more and more until it gets to
be a delta distribution so over time
mirrors are going to be mirrors but in
the mean time we will be able to render
SDS light paths brilliant piece of work
and the comparison to other algorithms
what you should be looking out for is
path tracing with regularization on the
right and this is the only technique
that can render this eg the Euro
graphics logo reflected in the mirror